there tell people first of all about
ruckpack what is this this company and
product ruckpack is a peak performance
nutrition shot pure and simple
it's good ingredients it's the things
you need that your body needs to stay on
top to stay in peak performance at all
times ok so what's in it I mean is there
caffeine or what is it Oh captain and
that's a very very big point we have
zero caffeine in the product it's
vitamins minerals nutrients we have our
own proprietary blend but generally it's
things your body already wants to stay
healthy to have energy we just fill that
gap that you can't get from the perfect
meal every single time ok now one of the
things you cannot get every single time
when you're in the Marine Corps or
anywhere in the military is that perfect
meal particularly when you're in the
field or you've got an operation at the
focus on right tell us why you created
this so while we're on deployment to
Afghanistan my first trip to Afghanistan
actually with marine Special Operations
Command we were taking supplements just
because we had the MREs but you need the
time to eat the MRE and sometimes you
just don't have that time right so we're
taking supplements and we started
putting together you know why are we
taking four or five six or seven
different types of supplements why don't
we put it all in one place so we you
know we looked for a couple different
companies ask them to make it and when
they didn't we said you know what why
don't we make it ourselves so that's
what you did that's exactly what we did
we spent three or four months basically
making an in the field business plan and
where is it now tell us about the
company who's funded what how big it's
got so it is caught a lot of speed I
think we did maybe thirty five thousand
dollars in the first year revenue just
trying to get anyone that would buy it
we're in about a thousand stores now
we're sold online a truck PACOM will be
a nine thousand store starting in
January we'll be doing a couple national
chains chain wide and all this obviously
we got a pretty big bump off after we
were on Shark Tank but it continues to
be very well supported because it's a
great product the product is one thing
you bring something else to the party
right because you not only are ruckpack
but you also lecture teach and speak at
various events tell us for example what
you're going to be doing tomorrow right
well tomorrow I'll be right back in
class at the Naval Academy teaching
accounting and terrorist financing the
guys you just had with unite us I think
I met them at Columbia University
speaking there I want to go help vets
you know that's that's why we started
this company we hire we just launched
our veteran distributor program today so
tell us about that
so now you can go and get verified as as
a veteran at ruckpack comm once you do
you have your user account you can go
start selling ruckpack right now today
we never need to meet you don't need to
interview no phone calls
start making money right now what's the
business like for these kinds of energy
and nutrition drinks because there's a
lot of competition out there there's a
ton of competition there are a lot of
points of differentiation though from
what we bring to the table with ruckpack
so we know our story we know our product
we don't really get into who's better or
what's better we just know that that's
good to guys in the military men and
women do they use the product in the
military they do we ship a lot overseas
and now that's actually an option online
now as well so you can buy and you can
ship some overseas you can get some and
give some at the same time what any new
any sort of new products on the horizon
or new flavors well this is a brand new
flavor that we just launched this week
for Veterans Day anniversary we've
launched our blood orange shot blood
oranges are so you got two flavors now
right yes
tropical peach and blood orange and why
don't you pick a lot orange was this a
taste test it's yeah we oh god it was a
taste test we've tasted several
different flavors that's the best one it
just it works well with the ingredients
that we have in there so why fight it it
works let's go with that has it changed
your love affair with meals ready to eat
with MREs you can't change that love
affair no you know that you're right
yeah you can't change that right that's
right but in terms of calories I mean is
this is this as a supplement that
replaces a meal or is this designed to
give you that boost let's say if you've
got a strenuous activity I've got an
athletic event I use it go with the meal
I use it for athletic events so it has a
lot of the electrolytes in there it's a
lot of people use it as a sports
recovery drink you know their drinking
water the entire event and now they're
going to drink ruckpack on there for the
recovery as well is this also a response
to the necessity of different kinds of
trician out in the field and you think
that the government that that would be
part of maybe it's not an MRE but it
would be something else I mean we're
surprised when you were in theater that
the food was well the food no I think
that you know you need to you think of
that MRE
what it's designed to do something like
my product you know we're going to have
to you're going to have to have some
shelf life in there you know you need to
be able to develop something for
millions of troops over time it's going
to be an MRE exactly what it is right
there's not too much is that what you
would like to do you want to get this
into the into the kits of we do we want
to develop something that's going to
match well with the MRE so it just it
throws those micronutrients on top of
the macronutrients that they providing
it just it's a nice blend can you
describe a situation in which you were
deployed where it was just horrible
weather and you just really were not
going to go and eat a regular meal and
you wish you had something like this
yeah I just want one
go ahead much time to you have we had a
I had two deployments to Afghanistan
there are a couple times where I've gone
over 7500 foot Peaks two feet of snow
you know that typical thing snowing
uphill both ways
trip in and trip out and that entire
time like there's just not a lot of time
to stop and rest and oh I'm just going
to hunker down here for the next half
hour and have a meal so there have been
a lot of times that I really wish I had
a rucksack throw it down keep going and
it keeps you in the fight exactly why we
made